a lot of people don't want to fly a lot
of people calling this the summer of
travel hell we're talking widespread
flight cancellations delays lost bags
airlines based in these united states
canceled more than 120 000 flights
between january and july of this year a
hundred and twenty thousand this morning
the points guy is releasing its sixth
annual best airlines report to help
consumers book their next getaway
in this country coming uh in at number
five we're gonna do the countdown alaska
airlines number four american airlines
and number three united airlines number
two
southwest and topping the list for the
fourth year in a row delta airlines
brian kelly is ceo and founder of the
point sky you are the original points
guys
they're clarified i got to be clear
original recipes concerned about this
yes i was concerned at bastion at delta
number one you're the guy that's the
fourth year in a row uh what is going on
with delta would allow them to do that
in other words what factors are you
looking at yeah the four main factors we
looked at the biggest was reliability
right because no matter if your budget
or luxury everyone wants to get to where
they're going on time so that was 30 of
our overall score the second factor was
the experience we actually put some
weight this year on family travel and
the airlines that are nice to families
delta now actually has family seating so
that got them a little extra love
the third was cost and
reach of the route network because you
want to be able to go places on airline
and then the final thing is 25 we're the
points guys so it's loyalty uh so
frequent flyer program we actually
checked to see if the airline offered
the seats because you can have you know
if you have points but you can't use
them what good is a point yeah so the
funny thing is delta didn't actually
come in number one in any of those
categories but they posted really strong
in all e's so very good in each category
exactly what about reliability yeah
reliability delta you know this has been
the year of flight cancellations uh
delta was extremely high but hawaiian
took number one which isn't shocking
when you think about hawaii are they
smaller
to hawaii yeah because you know they've
got pretty pretty darn good don't hold
it against them tony i know it's great i
wish i was on the flight right now so
that's why we had waitings for all those
different categories united number one
for reliability no for loyalty loyalty
yes sorry yes your return customers and
i will say united and southwest so delta
was by far the number one but uh united
was just a hair behind southwest for
that number two spot uh so uh but they
they came in number one for loyalty
their frequent flyer program's great and
what i love about united they have miles
on a mission which allows their members
to donate miles to charity which um so
many people don't want to travel who has
miles on a mission united airlines yeah
they allow their members to really
innovatively donate to charity which i
love but you still hear all the stories
about people saying it was terrible was
terrible
to the dot you know delta does do a good
job i flew them recently and you know
even though there was a delay at jfk
they put frequent fire miles
automatically in everyone's account so i
do think delta goes a step you know
above and beyond in the consumer they're
also the most expensive airline so i
think it's interesting though that and
they're profitable so consumers are
willing to pay to be treated like humans
i think that's the key theme we're
seeing and as a little bit of hope going
into the fall yesterday there were only
92 flight cancellations in the u.s
things are getting better i'm an
internal optimist
i'm hoping the airlines you know coveted
waves you know so what should travelers
start to consider as they get ready to
to get on a flight yeah i mean you've
always i always check my i use
flightaware which always check to see
where your aircraft's coming in from
you can set alerts uh for your flight
always get the airline app um and you
know when possible there are credit
cards that offer flight delay in
interruption coverage so just by putting
a flight on a credit card that has that
coverage built in if you're delayed in
the airport need to get a hotel room
usually the airlines won't cover that
but your credit card can so always look
to your credit card coverage brian kelly
you're the best appreciated the original
points guys that's right the original oh
yeah the original recipe over there